so Eliot has decided not to take down
the apparent villain until the apparent
villain Terry Colby pulls this bonehead
move during the meeting and remember
they're at this meeting because they
want to find out who hacked them Colby
Terry Colby the apparent villain disses
Angela Angela remember is a in a sexist
world and her big problem is she doesn't
have the confidence to be able to stand
up to these guys and Colby starts
talking to her and she makes a critical
mistake she gives him the wrong date of
when the incident took place and you
guys know if you have a boss who doesn't
like you they're always looking for a
reason to fire you yes and when Angela
makes this little mistake which doesn't
really mean much and the great scheme of
things Colby suddenly goes wait a minute
you gave me the wrong date this this
attack didn't happen on that day it
happened the day before and suddenly
he's talking to Tyrell who remembers a
real villain sing get her out of the
meeting get her out of the meeting and
angela is literally thrown out of her
own meeting and the apparent villain the
old white guy says to Elliott our hero
you're the one who stopped the hack
we're gonna talk to you about it subtext
you're a guy you're a computer guys
she's just a girl now remember Elliot
was about to not frame this old guy when
he sees what she did and what he did to
Angela he changes and remember it is the
emotional change in the hero that lets
him solve the crime in a mystery Spiller
he defends Angela in his heart he says
screw you to Colby I am gonna frame you
it's a brilliant change right in the
speech and he takes the file that will
frame Colby and he says here it is now
guys this is what i mean by having the
obstacle in the climate's point in one
act the obstacle point comes in the
middle of act 4 but then the climax
comes soon after and the climax is when
he says I
and a frame him he frames him and then
the story answers the question will
Elliott connect with Angela also it
answers the question will Elliott fight
the big guys but he remember in a
mystery thriller the real villain is
hidden so when he does this nothing
happens when we open her next act he's
just waiting the FBI doesn't get get
nobody gets it nobody digs up the dirt
on Colby and for 19 days nobody busts
Colby we see him wrap up his shrink plot
he hopes his shrink uncover her rat
boyfriend he uses his super powers to
find out the boyfriends quadruple timing
Elliott shrink and he helps her but
we're gonna wrap up the b2 and here's
how we do it for 19 days l eight Anjali
don't communicate but when they do they
do it this way have you ever had a if
you're a guy who ever had a girl tell
you don't condescend and try to help me
in a particular way because you're being
condescending as you do Angela finally
tells Elliot you know what you stepped
in and tried to help me at that meeting
I didn't want you to do it that way I
want you to help me when I asked you for
it not in a way that undermines me this
is her having the confidence to tell
Elliot what she really wants and she's
asking Elliot to care enough about her
to do it her way and he does he's got
Asperger's but he still does and in this
moment in the story if this was a movie
they would clinch and kiss they both
want to do it but remember this is
television they are never going to fall
in love or if it's going to take eight
years so they simply stare at each other
with longing looks but we've answered
the bee story question Angela Elliot
have connected emotionally that's and
she's developed confidence knowing how
to be your own person in a business
meeting
and he's developed caring I care enough
about you to do it the way you want
she's teaching him how to care about her
don't ever stick up for me that way
again now since there's no romance
because it's TV we end on our a
storyline will Elliott find the real
villain and now as he walks out into
times square he sees on the big screen
Terry Colby arrested Terry Colby was
behind the attack on his own company and
Elliott puts his hands up in the air and
he goes yes yes yes I've done it I've
got it I've vanquished the real villain
but remember this is a mystery thriller
and in mystery thrillers the villains
often win this happens in Chinatown this
happens in even in a way in LA
confidential this happens a lot and as
Elliott celebrating two bloomin and
black suits while the cops watch and do
nothing bustle Elliott into a limo and
they arrest him and they take him to the
same place we started this pilot and
remember where we started this pilot
there are people who control this world
and their shadow and we don't know who
they are and then at the beginning of
the movie of the television show we saw
them as shadowy figures and now what do
we see we're about to meet the real
villain the one percent of the one
percent and this time that shadowy group
of people has a light on them and it's
tyrell and he says hi Elliott we've been
waiting for you the real villain has one
and the story has just begun this guy's
is fabulous television using all the
patterns of the mystery thriller and all
the patterns I've taught you right now
this is what's happening in television
today this is why television is so good
you